what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and black panther 2 is
officially one week away I'm super
excited for everybody to see it I'm
super excited to hear everybody's
thoughts on it I think everybody is
really going to like it however I do
think a lot of people are really really
going to miss the presence of Chadwick
Bozeman if you manage to catch my
reaction after I saw it a couple of
weeks ago you know that that's how I
felt I thought the movie was great there
were a lot of fantastic parts to it but
you can notice the absence of Chadwick
Boseman no obviously sadly he passed
away and in my personal opinion without
recasting him or bringing in a
completely new character the movie that
I saw the movie that everybody will see
is the best possible version of the film
that they could have made they did the
best with what they had and I'm excited
for everybody to see it but today I want
to talk about kind of a sad story I'm
just gonna be completely honest a story
that I read about Ryan cougar and how he
found out about the passing of Chadwick
Boseman and about how Chadwick actually
didn't want to see the script for black
panther 2 because presumably he knew he
was about to pass away it's a really sad
story just going to be candid about it
but I think people should know this
because it really shows that even until
Chadwick's death he really didn't tell
anybody besides his family he really
thought he was going to power through
and make black panther 2 and of course
continue on with his already amazing
career so let's talk about this story
that Ryan coogler told himself while
speaking on the official black panther
podcast with the host ta nahisi Coates
and my apologies if I did not pronounce
that right on the podcast Coates asked
where were you in the script when you
found out he passed and Ryan coogler
said I just finished it man my last
conversation was calling him asking him
if he wanted to read it before I got
notes from the studio that was the last
time we spoke and yeah so I you know he
passed maybe a couple weeks after I
finished Ryan coogler then goes on to
talk about how he could tell Chadwick
was tired when he talked to him and he
could tell that something was up
remember Chadwick didn't really tell
anybody outside of a few people in his
family so Ryan coogler didn't know that
he had cancer at this time and I just
want to say I've said this before but I
want to say it again this says so much
about Chadwick's character but the
interview goes on and it says it's all
good what did you say coogler said he
was tired bro I could tell he was tired
I've been trying to get a hold of him
for a few days and Denzel Washington had
been trying to get a hold of him too so
I texted him and told him hey man Denzel
said he's been looking for you because
he just did Marini for Denzel so he
called me and I could tell he was laying
down we were talking and Simone Bozeman
his wife was with him and Ryan coogler
kind of gave a laughter in the podcast
as he said and he kicked Simone out
because he told her he didn't want her
to hear nothing that could get him in
trouble with the NDA the non-disclosure
agreement and she didn't want to leave
him so I could tell something was up but
they were joking and laughing and this
kind of hits you pretty hard he's laying
down he's tired you can tell he's
fighting this he's pretty much at the
end of it but he's still laughing and
he's still joking and he's still
light-hearted and trying to make the
best of a horrible situation but Ryan
coogler would go on to say that he
finished the Black Panther 2 script and
he would ask Chadwick if he wanted to
read it before he sent it to the studio
for notes coogler says he talked about
how they were planning their wedding in
South Carolina and how many people he
was going to invite and he asked about
my kid because he had missed our baby
shower and then he was like yeah he said
he didn't want to read it because he
didn't want to get in the way of
whatever notes the studio might have so
he was like it's better if I can read it
later but I found later that he was too
tired to read anything and sadly he
would never go on to actually read the
Black Panther 2 script however as we're
about to talk about in just a bit he
always did want Namor to be in the
second black panther film him and Ryan
coogler actually really talked about how
they want to name more but at the time
the rights to the character were a
little messed up and they couldn't
exactly use Namor at the time so they
didn't think it was possible so I'm sure
it would make Chadwick really really
happy to know that Namor was in Black
Panther too we'll talk about that in
just a bit but first big thank you to
Mint mobile for sponsoring this video
most people know about mobile because of
Ryan Reynolds but most people don't know
about mint Mobile's amazing quality now
I live in the mountains and service
isn't too good however mint mobile sent
me a free plan and I get better service
with their plan than I do with my other
provider but what's crazy is their plan
is so much cheaper mint mobile offers
Wireless for just 15 bucks a month they
give you the best rate whether you're
buying for one or a family and at mint
mobile families start at only two lines
all plans come with unlimited talk and
text plus high-speed data delivered on
the nation's largest 5G Network plus
mint Mobile's Modern Family Plan lets
you mix and match data plan so everyone
gets the amount of data that's right for
them and you can use your own phone and
keep your same number and contacts so to
get your new Wireless plan for just 15
bucks a month including the Modern
Family Plan go to mintmobile.com Cosmic
that's mintmobile.com Cosmic cut your
wireless build down to 15 bucks a month
at mintmobile.com
Ryan coogler would go on to say that he
was really excited to show Chadwick the
script and how they were excited talking
about new possible characters for the
sequel he said yeah man I did I knew I
wanted to make another one and when I
was doing my deep dive you know all
these stories there were a few
characters he would interact with I
thought this would be awesome and I knew
it would be claw and killmonger for the
first one but Namor was all over these
books and I thought it was really
interesting so we would say man could we
ever do Namor and they had contractual
things going on with him as a character
at the time but it was something that if
we ran it back it would be about him and
Namor and we would introduce Marvel's
Atlantis into that fold Ryan coogler
would go on to say that it was a couple
of weeks after he finished the script
for black panther 2 that he found out
that Chadwick passed away and he tells
the story about how he found out he
passed away as well he says yeah I was
at the house and I got a call from
Charles King and Craig costell Charles
King is my manager and Craig castels my
agent at WME so they call because they
heard because I guess all the big
agencies and managers kind of found out
before it broke in the press and they
called and told me that and you know I
didn't want to believe it so I called
Denzel and I spoke with him and I was
like maybe it's a rumor you know so I
was texting Chad you know you go through
that denial and with technology I think
it makes it kind of easier to deny
things you know what I'm saying you
think maybe it's a hoax or it's XYZ let
me text him let me call him you know
what I'm saying so I texted him and then
I told Denzel man check to see if it's a
rumor he was like I should do that so he
checked he called me back and he was
like it's not a rumor and then my agents
called back and said that the release
had just been posted so that was how I
found out which is a pretty
heartbreaking story he had just talked
to Chadwick two weeks earlier asking him
if he wanted to read the Black Panther 2
script probably pretty excited about
Namor the Submariner but at the time
Chadwick didn't really have the strength
to read it so he didn't and I actually
remember when this happened I remember
that it was kind of announced that
Chadwick had died we didn't get the
official statement yet so there was a
lot of confusion on whether or not it
was actually a real report and I
remember thinking the same thing this
could just be a rumor but then his
family released the statement that he
passed away leaving no doubt of the fact
that it was true now it's a sad story
but I do think that Chadwick would be
happy with how black panther 2 turned
out I think he would be excited for
Neymar the Submariner to be in the film
and I think he would be excited about
how great of performance is the rest of
the cast gave and how they really held
up the movie without him but I am
excited to hear what everybody thinks of
this film and I am excited for people to
see the acting in this film because it
truly is great because it's partially
real it's these people losing a friend
dealing with that grief on camera so
it's kind of amazing but sad but let me
know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below and let me know how
excited you are for Black Panther or two
that comes out one week from today don't
forget to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest MCU news and of
course like the video and for live
updates you can follow me on Instagram
and Twitter as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf wolf